i mean like what do you think the trolls
wanted out of all this because just
entertainment probably entertainment
yeah and more signature comics at that
time they were really really looking
forward to the song she was like a hot
commodity at the time really was it that
good it was very
than chris for a very long time yeah uh
as like an internet meme yeah um and
then now i feel like uh it's very much
flipped yeah yeah why was this why did
the sonic 2 corp the comic like gain
popularity well
well because sonichu as a comic was
created first by chris when they were i
think from 21
from 21 years old and it looks like it's
drawn by someone considerably younger
like a
five-year-old for example
so chris didn't have the most amazing
art skills chris did not right or
storytelling skills better than me
any kind of skills honestly but so so
that's why um this uh ridiculousness
of the comics was the appeal for a long
time and also chris started to focus
more on the chris and quickville rather
than sonichu a lot of the times and uh
and beating and beating up um trolls
trolls and the and the security guards
yeah yeah
yeah whenever anything bad happened in
chris's life often it would be appearing
in the uh comic is like a kind of uh you
know when you get insulted and then you
go back home and you remember how you
should have responded right yeah it's
almost like that
instead of being like i should have said
that at the moment chris is like i'm
going to draw the scenario in which i
come out on top as the sigma male right
it's uh it's the thought you have in the
shower yeah yeah shampoo bottles
clapping you yeah exactly
and during this time uh the trolls were
accusing chris of being gay which chris
did not agree with excuses very
homophobic at that time very homophobic
and very very straight according to
chris
uh so so to prove this chris drew an
entire episode of the comic where
chris's character sonic turned rose to
have very explicit sex
in this in the so-called comic how do
you prove you're not gay
that's how you do it clearly
my god that was a thing but then actual
because you know i understand like
sonichu and rosechu
not real ips right but then later down
the road weren't like actual ips used in
the in the like youtube
was a character right what yeah
eventually i guess i didn't go up to the
comics that that far well or i think me
too is only married to chris yeah
mutation
that's all right mewtwo is married to
chris in the quickville dimension that's
right no no in this dimension
sorry guys sorry
i also you know i feel like these
details aren't aren't important right
this isn't this is not an important
detail what did what is an important
detail i don't know i think it's an
important detail why why is it an
important detail because we have a
person who is like in this dimension
i am with mewtwo
let's go to a smash tournament
[Music]
why there's a difference between meaning
mitsu and being with mewtwo
and i'm just like damn here's child
bearing hips yeah
of course
is that a boyfriend free girl
like is it is is that is that what
mewtwo is yeah boyfriend
boyfriend free girl is that in the
pokedex description of mutants who have
no
of course yeah
chris used to be anti-asexual so
anti-asexual yeah chris had a problem
with people who didn't want to have sex
right the gay the gay people and the
asexual people too right because i
believe that chris was once rejected by
a girl and because she said that she was
asexual so oh
okay i don't think that's what i was
gonna say i was like that seems like a
very weird hill to die
actually at least twice but anyway the
mewtwo thing is because of the idea guys
right the previously mentioned trolls
which convinced chris that they were in
a relationship with both with
both throats threes
there's there's three husbands and wives
mewtwo magic chance sonichu and chrysler
rose true
how very progressive i think
wait what was the second one
magic chan sonichu
which is that which is a different
character from the sonichu comics
magician
and they they put that idea in chris's
head
well yes
the marriage idea yes
wait why do they do this
what do they have to gain from it from
convincing chris that they were married
to mewtwo for the wolves
for the lols of course but the walls
this this sounds like the worst like
offspring of inception that i've ever
seen yeah
this is literally the worst inception
movie